yeah so uh we sell nft domains and these
are uh on chain on using a suite of
smart contracts and uh it allows you to
map any type of information you would
want from a name like mat.crypto to say
let's say a bitcoin address a litecoin
address an ethereum address what have
you for sending cryptocurrency payments
that's the hero on fire use case that
most people are using uh this tech for
right now um but longer term obviously
we think you're going to add a bunch
more stuff to your domain names people
are already adding profile pictures uh
they're linking their twitter they're
verifying credentials about themselves
uh so there's there's a lot that this
can do but in the short run it's mostly
about making payments uh you know 10
times easier for normal people we are
technology agnostic you know we're not
tied to any given blockchain like you
know ethereum or anything else we
actually view ourselves as an
application that exists to make it
easier uh for users regardless of what
crypto assets they want to use we also
don't have any renewal fees so we really
took the nft approach that every other
nft on the planet has uh where you buy a
domain once and you own it forever
and then we are laser focused on making
sure this is accessible for everyone on
the planet so one of the things that we
do is we actually cover the gas fees so
it's absolutely free to mend and set up
your uh nft domain through ensemble
domains this is a commitment that we
want to hold for our users going forward
um because we think that you really need
to understand the full cost of ownership
for these things to make them usable for
everybody so you know when we say we
think that there should be an nft domain
name in all three billion people on the
planet's wallet uh that means that you
know they need to cost five dollars or
less uh and and you need to have gas
fees be basically minimal or else uh
you're just not gonna be able to get it
in these countries where you know the
average income for the month may be 250
bucks if that's the cost of the gas fees
for registering your domain name then
that's a no-go i think as of yesterday
we have 1.8 million domains registered
this is you know three or four x maybe
5x any of the other people in our space
we've also
have four of the top five most popular
domain extensions so you
know.crypto.zil.wallet.nft
these are for the top five blockchain
naming services they're all offered by
unstoppable domains and we're seeing
just super rapid growth we registered
more domain names in the past four
months than have been registered by any
other system over the past four years
our integration count year over year is
up 600
uh we're projecting similar numbers
going into next year so we're seeing an
explosion in these utility nfts and
that's kind of our category here with uh
blockchain nft domains as uh identifiers
on the internet and i think that whole
space is just that to continue growing
uh strongly in the next year and over
the next three to five years users want
choices i i would that's how i would you
know couch that so we make it easy for
users to meet their domains to their
wallet
they can wait to claim their domains
when they're ready or they can even
store their domains in a custodial
exchange like gemiini so we actually
think about it a suite of options for
users on how they want to store domains
and uh
you know i think people should claim the
domain that they intend to use on a
daily basis to their self-custody wallet
i mean that's what you should do but
it's kind of like coinbase right like
coinbase on board is 70 million people
you go on there you buy your bitcoin uh
and then when you withdraw that bitcoin
your personal wallet that's when you
take full ownership of that and that's
how we view on subtle domains we're an
onboarding point for people to get into
web3 and decentralized web we make it
super easy for you to come to our site
pick out a domain name that you'd want
to have
and then you can claim that to your
wallet you know when you're ready and i
think that's great for users and i think
it also points out another thing which
is people are still very scared when
interacting with uh
with blockchain and crypto in general
and that's something we as an industry
need to do better to make people feel
comfortable claiming these assets to
their self-custody wallet
so on the growth side i would say it's
looking very positive because we are
we are seeing three to five hundred
percent year-over-year growth basically
and it's actually close to four to five
hundred percent over year growth and
we're actually seeing domain name
registrations um actually over a
thousand actually every year we expect
that to improve as well if you think
about it in terms of bitcoin like
bitcoin's average appreciation is probab
or adoption is 60 to 100 per year and so
you know blockchain domain right now is
growing at closer to four to five
hundred percent year every year so you
project that over a five ten year period
that means we're going to get everyone
adopted eventually uh we are still very
very early though this is something i
tell my team there's about 250 000
people using nft domains right now and
there's 250 million people who have
cryptocurrency in some sort of wallet so
we have a thousand x to go just in order
to catch up with the current users and
that 250 million users that use crypto
today is going to keep growing at
60 to 100 percent year over year so uh i
think we need to step on the gas even
harder to make the growth rate go faster
it is positive right now because we are
growing faster than the overall adoption
of crypto but i think we can i think we
can go even faster than that so we'll
see we'll put the rocket boosters on